[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerradas
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana tratamos un tema
realmente apasionante a partir de la
situación tan cruda que está viviendo el
mundo nos preguntamos si tras esta
pandemia vamos a vivir una especie de
felices años 20 unos años de frenesí
unos años locos para contestar esta
pregunta me acompañan en este estudio
ricardo tara corresponsal del diario 'el
espectador' en parís bienvenido ricardo
muchísimas gracias
miriam leiva editorial de la revista
chic magazine bienvenido miriam hola a
víctor alfonso crítico gastronómico
bienvenido hola carlos
habrá desenfadado y felices años 20 tras
la crisis sanitaria hoy en primera plana
son varias las voces incluso del ámbito
académico que apuestan por unos años
locos tras la pandemia años de liberarse
de consumo de desenfreno en todos los
enfoques de la vida del económico al
sexual lo dice por ejemplo el
investigador de sociología de la
universidad de james
nicholas christakis en su último libro y
no es el único
cuesta proyectarse todavía en esa etapa
cuando la variante delta del virus está
arrasando en el planeta pero quizás es
un ejercicio de esperanza intrínseco al
ser humano en estos momentos de crisis
hoy hablaremos de secuelas de la
pandemia en el mundo de después
intentando vaticinar lo que nos espera
antes repasemos algunas portadas que nos
deja este asunto jugada internacional
mañana los años locos habla el rotativo
de innovación creación o liberación
sexual tras la pandemia la revista
bloomberg businessweek también apunta a
esta portada esta teoría de vuelta de
los a los locos años 20 el país dedica
por su parte un artículo también este
asunto titulado caminamos hacia nuevos
años de hedonismo tras la pandemia
hablaremos también de ese concepto de
don ismo
con la salida a la crisis para empezar
os quiero preguntar a los tres si creen
en esa teoría de vuelta a los sueños
locos tras la pandemia recargo pues se
habría que empezar por pensar si
realmente los años veinte fueron tan
locos tan felices para todo el mundo y
por todas partes donde pronto tenemos
una imagen un poco idealizada de lo que
fue esa época en la que europa estaba
reconstruyendo se en la que de todas
maneras no no no hubo un proceso rápido
o una crisis que no se resolvió y que
finalmente desembocó en la en la crisis
económica de 29 años a nivel mundial
entonces por un lado tal vez los años 20
no fueron tan felices y tan locos tal
vez el arte nos hace creer algo que fue
una parte de una de las muchas facetas
de los años 20 que hemos identificado es
posible yo lo veo así
miriam
creo que es un poco temprano para saber
yo me siento un poco perdida y creo que
no soy la única que queremos que vuelva
en los años felices pero no sé si es
posible por ahora y estamos en europa y
es diferente en europa y en otras partes
del mundo creo que es muy difícil
pensarlo en una visión mundial que lo
pensamos como franceses y hay que
pensarlo de manera el rural globalizada
y eso es algo muy difícil para por ahora
yo no sé contestar a esa pregunta
aitor yo creo que efectivamente la
imagen que tenemos de los años 20 es una
imagen también de las élites no decir
esa imagen de que has viviendo champagne
en los cabarés de parís hombre pues
también son años en que por ejemplo se
marcan mucho las las diferencias no las
las desigualdades ahora bien no sé yo
creo que yo tampoco soy muy optimista la
verdad al menos en los dos de tres años
venideros yo creo que el año que viene
va a ser muy muy bueno en lo económico y
después ya se verá
siempre que esperar no siempre que
esperar pero ya se verá
hablábamos decía mi compañero riccardo
que lo mejoremos mitificado un poco esos
años 20
si hacemos el mismo que semejanza así
que diferencias
encontramos con la situación actual
recordemos que tras los años 20 vino
también el crack del 29 luego el auge de
los fascismos el auge del antisemitismo
también
yo pienso que una diferencia importante
es que la guerra
las guerras en general tienen un punto
final al menos las guerras mundial no
tuvieron un armisticio en el que terminó
todo al día siguiente la gente sabría
celebrar en un frenesí mientras que la
pandemia ha tenido como ha tenido hasta
ahora un par de falsos finales en los
que la gente se puso muy contenta y
regresó yo creo que ahora la gente ha
perdido un poco la esperanza de un final
abrupto es decir hay precauciones que
habrá que seguir teniendo el miedo a las
variantes valorar un poco entonces no
veo a alguien no de un momento que puede
ser que se puede es el punto final vamos
a irnos de fiesta va a ser un proceso
lento lento lento y la gente va a tener
miedo por un buen tiempo este final
abrupto ya no se ve como decía ricardo
llegan las variantes entonces se frene
si a lo mejor ya no va a ser tanto como
pensábamos que iba a ser esa final de la
crisis todo el mundo de fiesta es la
diferencia creo con unos años 20 del
siglo 20 es que no sabemos si habrá una
final
a bruto hablamos de una guerra en los
años 20 del siglo 20 y había también una
pandemia de gripe pero se acabó
en la crisis actual no sabemos si va a
acabar en un año cinco años diez años
así que por eso tengo deuda hace unos
meses te habría dicho si hay un
agradecía queremos vivir eso pero ahora
ya no sé por qué no vemos la salida y la
diferencia también creo es que tenemos
otros temas muy preocupantes como pienso
en el cambio climático o la relación a
la consumación etcétera que son muy
distintas de lo que pasaba en los años
20 del siglo 20 hay una urgencia en el
planeta y tal y hay muchos otros
problemas que no tenían y que tenemos
que enfrentar en fin enfrentar ahora y
son más urgente creo que la pandemia
un poco de mística del rupturismo no es
el momento mágico del antes y el después
a partir del cual todo cambiaría hombre
es un motor de la utopía está claro pero
lo que tenemos que tener una
consideración un poco más realista más
política también
de lo que es la vida colectiva y de cómo
puede cambiar para mejor en el corto
plazo desde luego no estamos ahí no
estamos en el momento del frenesí
tenemos el hito de inventar vacunas en
10 meses que ha sido algo inédito pero
también el desafío de las variantes
luego también habrá que hacer frente
digamos a las secuelas psicológicas que
deja esta crisis como digamos en una
etapa próxima la postcrisis entonces
tendrá escenarios progresivos distintos
sí creo que un punto muy importante es
las bueno las modificaciones a nivel
social el hecho de que la pandemia o
ligón encierro que obligó a un consumo a
domicilio de cultura de comida a la
ruptura de muchos lazos sociales y que
ya era un proceso que había empezado con
uber con amazon con netflix y que se ha
centrado y que se ha agudizado porque la
gente en un momento tenía miedo de salir
y se acostumbra finalmente a que todo
llegue a su casa entonces yo creo que la
relación con la ciudad con los espacios
públicos va a cambiar
yo supongo que la gente va a ir mucho
menos al cine al teatro a esos gatos los
damos por rotos o sea los damos por hay
un cambio hay un cambio yo imagino que
no va a haber la misma cantidad público
para los espectáculos en general porque
mucha gente se acostumbra a consumir la
cultura que le llegue y nos falta la
cultura creó especialmente en parís
donde los de los apartamentos son
pequeños y creo que hay una frecuencia
hora de ir al cine en el teatro porque
faltó mucho y en los restaurantes pero
es muy difícil hablar de todo el mundo
porque hay tantas tendencias diferentes
a nivel social niveles sociales y
dependencias muy distintas efectivamente
porque sí que hablamos de esas ganas de
ir al teatro de ir al cine porque ha
faltado eso pero también hay mucha gente
que se ha aproximado la cultura y que le
ha salvado la cultura estos meses de
confinamiento y se han podido acercar a
perspectivas culturales que no tenían en
sus propias vidas eso también le ha
pasado a gentes hay hay gente que nunca
habían visto tantas películas
no sé hay nuevos modos de vida de
consumación pero es difícil y estamos en
parís que no refleja a toda francia no
sé no sé
aitor creo que tenemos ganas de salir
hay un apetito
muy fuerte en estas últimas semanas por
ir al restaurante y no solamente por
comer ya nos damos cuenta que lo que nos
faltó en el restaurante no es la comida
comer obviamente seguimos comiendo lo
que nos faltaba es el restaurante como
espacios espacios sociales como espacio
de encuentro como espacio teatral y ccoo
y los restaurantes cuando nos faltaron
nos dimos cuenta de que era una especie
de signos de puntuación de nuestras de
nuestras ciudades que señores de la
ciudad que no teníamos tiempo estamos
hablando de dos mundos el restaurante
teatro cine digamos sin cierto cine tal
vez más comercial al mismo tiempo el el
mcdonald's el caerse la gente se
acostumbró y uno ve las enormes
cantidades de personas que llevan a
domicilios a su casa sí y ahí es decir
hay ahí hay gente para la que ir al
restaurante es una experiencia social
hay gente que al restaurante
y no está yendo y hablamos de la comida
rápida se está llevando a casa los
grandes cines los grandes estudios no
están lanzando sus películas disney no
las de sus películas en el cine sino en
vídeo entonces tal vez la para una
cierta élite que que se permite es esa
cultura que quiera que quiere quiere ir
al teatro porque es un espacio social o
algo al restaurante es una parte pero
para la cultura de massa
mucho del consumo se orientó hacia el
domicilio fijaos estáis hablando de
tendencias cruzadas es muy difícil
imaginarse qué mundo va a salir de todo
esto es porque incluso tendencias que se
contradicen entre sí por ejemplo cuando
hablamos del terreno de lo económico
hemos hablado muchísimo durante esta
crisis que vamos a repensar nuestro
modelo de consumo que vamos a volvernos
más ecológicos que esta crisis ese es un
llamamiento de atención y al mismo
tiempo hablamos de a ver si se acaba
esto pronto para un frenesí un frenesí
de consumo para dar un arreón al consumo
parece contradictorio también y no
sabemos exactamente qué tendencias
definidas van a salir
lo acabamos de nombre de la cultura lo
podemos ver en el consumo no lo tenemos
claro como no nos imaginamos cómo hacer
ese 2025 cuando ya tengamos perspectiva
con la atalaya del tiempo verdad me
parece que estamos divididos en entre
corto plazo y largo plazo o bien a corto
plazo queremos el mundo de antes
queremos comprar ropa a salir y tal pero
a lo largo plazo cuando lo pensamos hay
muchos problemas lo hablamos un poco el
planeta de vital y sabemos que tenemos
que comprar y lo sabíamos antes y la
pandemia lo llamó la atención que
tenemos que también estamos en una
diferencia entre estructura grandes
estructuras de consumo y pequeños
lugares de vanguardia donde sí que allí
se lleva a cabo pues un intento de
cambiar nuestras maneras de consumo
nuestra relación con el viaje un viaje
más ecológico viajar menos viajar mejor
etcétera hay que esperar que pues esas
pequeñas tendencias de progreso terminen
siendo influyentes en las viajar pero
todos estamos esperando que no haya
restricciones
para tomar para viajar más son esas
contradicciones en las que las
planteamos hoy en primera plana porque
son contradicciones que suben enormes y
terribles que cada uno tiene que
afrontar es decir también cada uno pone
el límite donde cree que tiene que estar
puesto también existen otras modalidades
de viajar por ejemplo el tren de noche
que está volviendo fuerte por ejemplo en
el decir que hoy irá en un fin de semana
a milán o a edimburgo pues a lo mejor ya
lo iremos en avión pero aún pero pero de
nuevo es decir sigue siendo una cosa del
que lo puedo decir el tren es más caro
que el avión para viajar en europa es
decir que finalmente la gente que va ir
a milán por un fin de semana de tal vez
a consumir en los restaurantes de lo más
elegante si no hay comida rápida va
igual tomar el avión entonces ahora que
nos replanteamos nuestra manera de
consumir quién quién y quién todo el
mundo no creo para viajar lo que pasa es
que es muy complicado y hay mucha gente
que a quién no le gusta tanto viajar y
prefieren no esperar tres horas en el
aeropuerto hacer tres títeres with you'
viaje hace dos semanas y es una
expedición es interesante porque me
parece que el viaje como
como una aventura y también reinventar
pues un viaje más asequible de la misma
manera restauración de algo y
restaurante el que va de barrio también
es un lugar social de encuentro es decir
la gente se reúne y me van a dar unos
segundos hacemos una pequeña pausa en
este punto y en unos instantes
continuamos aquí en el debate en primera
plana hasta ahora
[Música]
france24 otro punto de vista
liberté égalité actual y t
seguimos en primera plana quienes
refieren france24 habrá desenfreno y
felices años 20 en el mundo de la post
pandemia va a ser esto sodoma y gomorra
es la cuestión que nos planteamos con
nuestros invitados intentando poner un
punto de distensión a esta situación
desde luego pandémica que nos asola lo
hacemos con ricardo está la corresponsal
del espectador en parís miriam leiva
editora de la revista chic magazine y
aitor alfonso crítico gastronómico
hablamos de muchos conceptos como
derroche económico consumo frenesí
sexual innovación hedonismo búsqueda del
placer de todos ellos cuáles ven más
enfocados a la etapa de la post pandemia
recargo
sexual y sexual ya había y
y frenesí solitario pero donde en varias
hay gentes que ahora quieren salir
julie y yo no veo mucha gente en frente
sexual ahora pero lo que leí hay gente
que sí ahora que ya están vacunadas
salida salen hacen fiesta creo que es
también una cuestión de edad los jóvenes
salen mucho en parís ahora los jóvenes
están de fiesta quieren sexual tu vida
social en estas situaciones es terrible
psicológicamente así que el chascarrillo
de si va a haber unos años de frenesí y
sodoma y gomorra les quiero preguntar
una reflexión quizá que vaya un poco más
profunda es decir creen por ejemplo una
liberación sexual como resultado que
salga de esta crisis es decir enfocó más
del sexo en una perspectiva política
incluso no sé creo que cambiaron algunas
cosas de la frenesí que había antes
mucha gente dicen que ya no quieres ya
no quieren eso que quieran alguien para
porque el confinamiento fue muy duro
pero también ahora es el verano
de lo contrario si también pasa y es
interesante porque ahora es el verano y
todo está abierto en francia y hace
solitar así que creo que vamos a tener
una pequeña sodoma y gomorra este verano
pero sabemos en contrario al año pasado
sabemos que en septiembre ya la fiesta
se va a acabar así que hay un poco de
miedo también lo que leí también es que
nos acostumbramos a no tocarnos y eso es
una realidad y no sabemos de cuánto
tiempo eso va a durar y tal vez va a
comprar muchas cosas pero más allá del
sodoma y gomorra del frenesí sexual me
refiero a que si digamos en los momentos
de reflexión es de momentos más
reflexivos del confinamiento valen
también para enfocar o para replantearse
la vida sexual y avanzar hacia hace una
liberación sexual en el plano que sea
eso lo creen aitor hombre yo creo que
eso es un trabajo en trabajo que toma
mucho tiempo y mucha energía y que venía
y además lejos es decir la cuestión
replantear la liberación sexual es que
le exigimos mucho al cobismo en realidad
si pensamos que este virus
va a cambiar de cabo a rabo nuestras
vidas para un mejor iba que vamos a
vivir desnudos
después de esto ojalá pero no lo creo es
decir que hay estructuras mucho más
dominantes que este virus en el y que
determinan de manera más profunda
nuestras vidas
va a ser muy gradual es decir en todos
los terrenos va a ser muy gradual las
tendencias que se pueden acentuar vamos
a ver un efecto a largo plazo yo no me
imagino una porque ya está ya había una
liberación sexual antes hay una que
vivimos un período de liberación y no
creo que el que el coit vaya a acelerar
universo detonante enorme acelerador
muchos artículos hacen referencia al
concepto del hedonismo tanto de consumo
rápido como de tema de frenesí sexual la
búsqueda del placer a la salida de la
crisis porque necesitamos de ese don
ismo la mejor de la gastronomía' se
pueda responder a esto yo creo que ir al
restaurante y repito que sea del que va
de barrio hasta un restaurante más
gastronómico pues es un momento yo creo
que de que no se extrae de la urgencia
también o del día a día
ir a un restaurante es entrar en otra
temporalidad es ir a buscar un placer
qué es lo que nos saca de una vida
una vida de urgencia en la cual de hecho
creo que el virus no sano nos ha metido
en profundidad es decir el tiempo del
cobi era un tiempo liso un tiempo un
tiempo hablando un tiempo raro no pero
buscar el hedonismo de una forma muy
urgente no es la mejor garantía de
pervivencia del sistema de no
replantearse el sistema es sin duda así
sino sino concientizar tu placer y lo
que cueste lo que implica pues está
claro que no el hedonismo jugar fuego a
favor del sistema en estos casos
ricardo no necesariamente no
necesariamente creo que esté pensando
pronto algo que se nos quedó por fuera
es el movimiento la gente hacia afuera
en las ciudades que también es
importante es a mucha gente abandonó a
las ciudades y y eso sí puede tal vez
producir nuevos modelos por ejemplo de
familias más nucleares porque pues en
una región rural no hay toda la
posibilidad de ser todos los contactos
no hay de pronto también la gente se
puede en otra dinámica que se suma estás
buscar más como su núcleo porque los
confinamientos nos acostumbran al núcleo
para unas personas fue desastroso si
quieren explotar para otras fue
descubrir algo
se vieron obligadas a convivir más en
círculos cerrados y hay gente que por su
personalidad o porque son introvertidos
les conviene y ahí hay un cambio tal vez
el profesor de sociología a nicholas
christakis de la universidad de yale es
el que uno de los que ha teorizado sobre
la vuelta a los años locos los felices
años 20 dice sin embargo que no es un
futuro inmediato habla lo fecha a partir
de 2024 es decir nos quedarían todavía
dos añitos y medio para llegar a esto es
decir antes de dos años y medio nada y
sí que dice que hay tendencias que
podemos visualizar bien típicamente dice
el profesor típicamente en periodos de
pandemia la gente se vuelve más
religiosa ahorra más dinero y le toma
más adversión al riesgo tiene menos
interacciones sociales y se queda más en
casa dejas de ver a tus amigos la
tolerancia el riesgo en todos los campos
de la vida parece algo intrínseco a la
salida de las crisis largas están de
acuerdo que cuanto menos así que esa
aversión al riesgo se neutraliza
es lo que hablaba antes del programa
usando la que avant lo vemos ahora que
después de un año en casa es difícil
para muchas personas salir tienen miedo
y no es solo miedo es algo de que
acostumbrarse te acostumbraste y ver a
gente te cuesta más el lazo social te
cuesta más y eso me da un poco de miedo
porque el ser humano necesita a los
demás y aveces aunque lo quieras no lo
puedes y los jóvenes vimos que había
mucha depresión muchos estudios y así
que tenemos que cuestionar eso y por eso
ahora yo no me esperaba eso para el
verano yo creía que que tendría más
euforia pero espero que en 2024 va a
llegar es que hay tantas cosas que no se
esperan que es muy difícil saber si hay
france y el resto del mundo también el
tour sí yo creo que no se nos digamos
limitado en las aventuras sociales no
seas bien sea salir y la restaurante
conocer a otra gente y está y
efectivamente yo creo que hay que re
aprender un poco esa disponibilidad
las micro aventuras no hay mucha gente
que sigue que sigue que será muy flipado
la verdad pero de nuevo en esta cuestión
yo vuelvo a la incoherencia un poco
porque claro hablamos de que nos cuesta
más ese lado social que nos hemos
acostumbrado menos y se supone que
durante esta crisis hemos estado una y
otra vez subrayando la cuestión de que
si vamos a ver si aprendemos que estamos
aprendiendo la cuidado del otro no que
es algo nos deja la crisis es la
importancia de los cuidados es un poco
contradictorio
lo interesante en qué punto nos
situaremos en la salida de la crisis
decir realmente qué tendencia habrá en
la a largo plazo a lo mejor lo de laszlo
live es interesante porque lo sabíamos
que necesitábamos más lo live más a
cuidar a tu vecino y eso lo aprendimos
este año creo que aprendimos de una
manera violenta a quedarnos en casa a
hacer menos cosas consumir menos y a ver
lo que va a quedar van a quedar cosas
buenas también ricardo sí pues
aprendimos pero también olvidamos o sea
mucha gente gana es escéptico soy muy
escéptico y yo pienso que los cambios no
se dan tan rápidamente y que hay unas
dinámicas
más allá de la decisión individual tú
personalmente no puedes ir voy a
consumir menos y hacer que el que yo no
creo que nadie aprendió a consumir menos
a la gente que ya tenía una conciencia
puede que se dijo es posible consumir
menos mire se puede la gente que no la
tenía yo no sé no creo que masivamente
el comido haya hecho pensar la mente
vamos a consumir menos usar se consumía
menos porque no había
pero el tema en el maquillaje por
ejemplo para las mujeres el
confinamiento las mujeres se dieron
cuenta que los tacones el maquillaje
todo eso era un poco superficial ay hubo
un artículo en nueva york que decía
ahora las mujeres quieren volver a poner
tacones y tal pero yo creo que para las
mujeres hay muchas y corrupción
que bajaron que tienen ahora un poco
menos de presión sobre el físico y hay
mucho más naturaleza ahora a ver si
queda hay también la tolerancia es es un
cambio que yo veo la tolerancia que la
gente a parte del trabajo tiene otra
vida sea la gente se acostumbró a que
aquí pues está trabajando sin sin tener
que estar vestido para el trago porque
está en casa que es la dra el perro y
ahora el niño y ya que eso que queda un
poco vergüenza si una llama profesional
se escuchan sus ríos ahora hacen toleró
de ahí puede tal vez hacer un cambio
positivo en admitir que la vida no es
sólo trabajo si el capitalismo lo
permiten piensa para más o menos la
gente de nuestra general
me puedo permitir decir que es la comida
hace un punto de inflexión es algo que
bueno que va a marcar nuestras vidas y
que vamos a recordar sin embargo muchos
expertos que dicen que no va a ser la
única pandemia que vamos a vivir en
nuestras vidas y les pregunto que
elecciones vamos a sacar de esta
pandemia para las pandemias futuras que
seguramente vamos a vivir según muchos
expertos las vamos a vivir porque
sabemos que si esas decisiones se toman
a nivel individual claro aquí lo que
viene son también las grandes los
grandes movimientos colectivos no si hay
una agencia ecológica que hay que
intentar solucionarlo en cuanto antes
está claro
pero también tiene que ver con
decisiones políticas a más alto nivel
pero por ejemplo esa hora se produjera
un kobe 21-22 sabríamos que hay ciertos
errores que no volveríamos a cometer yo
creo que el paralelo con los años 20
súper pertinentes salimos de la gran
guerra y dijimos aprendimos no habrá
otra guerra sabemos cómo manejar los
conflictos y el ser humano y el ser
humano
si yo también soy un poco pesimista
olvidamos mucho porque gracia
eso vivimos
la próxima vez que hay una oportunidad
vamos a llevar mascarillas no vamos a
esperar seis meses para hacerlo y creo
que haremos un cierto aprendizaje no
también nos ayuda el contacto físico el
issste baja y esto ahora aprendimos y lo
nos vamos a quedar con eso les organizar
en nuestros contactos físicos han
variado pero para toda la vida
esto me da un poco de miedo pero creo
que si está cambiando no se art hemos
perdido algunos reflejos no sé si van a
devolver
es un placer contar con ustedes hoy en
primera plana y sacar estas lecciones de
lo que puede dar esta pandemia a nivel
personal y de bueno ver más o menos qué
tendencias se pueden vislumbrar para el
escenario ahora por tándem ya muchísimas
gracias
eduardo miriam aitor y a todos ustedes
les esperamos a quien en primera plana
la próxima semana muchas gracias
[Música]